it definitely easy not to be aware how
much
sugar you're consuming. The American Heart Association
recommends that women consume twenty-five grams
of added sugar a day.  Its enlightening
picking up the large
candy bars or those single package
cookies
and see how many have them you cannot
eat
without going over that recommendation.
I'm excited for the new nutrition labels
which differentiates between the sugars
that are naturally occurring in the food
verses sugars that are added
by the food processor.  Yogurt – expecially
like a
a fruit yogurt, when I look at the amount
of sugar it's a very high number
but how much that sugar comes from milk
Milk has milk sugar it's not a sugar
that cause the same problems we see with
fructose sweetened beverages
fruit has sugar and they clearly put
some fruit in there
and then they've added sugar. I wanna know how much
is added sugar and I can't even tell and
I'm a registered dietitian who is
taken a lot of nutrition courses. So
the general public doesn't know either.